this month Habitat for Humanity is
raising awareness about the critical
need for affordable housing through its
home is key campaign since it was
founded in Georgia and 1976 Habitat for
Humanity has helped some 13 million
people in nearly 1400 communities around
the world a famous pair of homebuilding
brothers are helping the effort Jan
Crawford reports on how the property
brothers worked with one future
homeowner in Atlanta and unveiled a
special surprise if you watch the
television showed property brothers this
will be a familiar sight Jonathan Scott
working hard to fix up the home of
someone's dreams but at this
construction site here in Atlanta the
dreams are so much more than the perfect
home renovation this house they're
building with Habitat for Humanity for
an Atlanta mother of three true Sheeta
holt I finally get to say this is mine
this is ours Holt who works in a medical
office has never owned her own home
working side-by-side with other
volunteers including this high-powered
help
she says she's also setting an example
for her kids a lot of these families
that habitat works with you know they
never thought they would have a house
they could call their own and so for
them to be able to see this path to
that's you know achieving that goal that
means so much to us because you're
changing people's lives it's a hand up
not a hand out
habitat homeowners like holt pay their
own mortgages and volunteer to help
build other habitat homes this month the
property brothers as habitat
humanitarians are kicking off habitats
home is the key campaign to raise
awareness about the crisis and
affordable housing in the US where one
in six families pay half or more of
their income on their rent or mortgage
they join other habitat humanitarians
over the years Garth Brooks Trisha
Yearwood and former President Jimmy
Carter who last year worked beside our
own John Dickerson there's a difference
between you know house is just a
collection of studs and window
doors but a home is where is that safe
sanctuary for drew and Jonathan Scott is
a continuation of a relationship they've
been working with habitat since they
were in their late teens just starting
out flipping houses born in Canada they
are now a global brand with a show
broadcast in more than 160 countries
drew is the realtor helping families
find and buy fixer uppers Jonathan does
the heavy lifting to make the magic
happen while the family waits for the
big reveal
usually there's tears minor because of
sawdust oh yeah but with habitat it's
different there's something for me that
feels special when you look around and
you see all of these people who are
giving up their time to help a complete
stranger the home will be finished by
the end of the month but today the
brothers had a special reveal habitat
flew in Holt's oldest son who's in the
Army based in Hawaii for a surprise
visit the first she has seen him in more
than a year and just like that this
house is home now habitat also arranged
for her oldest son to stay in Atlanta
for a month to help them finish building
the home and we'll be there when they
get those keys to move in Nora
Wow Jam thank you there's nothing better
than that knowing you have a new home
for your family somewhere to be my
playin house and nothing better than
your son who you haven't seen coming
over and surprising you I like that I
hand up not a handout nice thanks Jan
we'll be right back